China's president Xi Jinping is this
week beginning another five-year term as
Communist party leader the fact that
it's his third is historic and it
cements him as China's most powerful
ruler in decades she's appointment was
confirmed over the weekend at a party
Congress in Beijing there he shook up
the party's senior ranks promoting
Loyalists and proteges to China's top
leadership while sweeping away factional
Rivals and for the first time in 25
years there are no women holding top
jobs in The Pollard Bureau we can speak
now to political scientists Professor
Steve Sung the director of the China
Institute at soas London Professor
welcome to DW news Asia regarding Xi
Jinping you've been quoted as saying
that we have seen the end of collective
leadership in China and that it's being
replaced by strongman rule in your
opinion what will she's third term in
power mean for China now and going into
the future
well it means now China is being
reshaped after XI jinping's image he has
now replaced anyone from other factions
within the Communist Party by his own
prodigies and proven loyalists they will
all say yes sir we will go and follow
you wherever you want to take us and
China is going to be rough for the rest
of the world
you've also said it all now depends on
she Jinping getting it right what does
he need to get right
well he needs to get everything right
because
he says that the party leads everything
everywhere in China and Beyond China
where China is concerned so he has to
get the con economy right he has to get
his foreign policy right he has to get
his social policy right if he doesn't do
so fake mistakes can be very can be made
and they will have consequences for the
people of China and also for the rest of
the world
could you outline some of what those
potential consequences might be
well the Civil Corbett policy for
example is causing
significant slowdown in the Chinese
economy the policy on the real estate
market is again causing economic or
financial instability in China if he
insists on using Force against Taiwan we
may be facing a situation when the
United States and China will be actively
in engaging in military hostilities with
each other
and you will also have continuation of
the kind of repression of people in Hong
Kong and in xinjiang amongst the bigger
people Professor there's been a
multi-party delegation from the German
parliament's human rights committee
that's been visiting Taiwan let's take a
listen to some of what it's had to say
and then we'll come back to you
we have noted XI jinping's intimidation
against Taiwan at China's 20th party
Congress
from our perspective Taiwan stands at
the center of the Rivalry between
systems I mean not only verbal attacks
on Taiwan but a real military threat
that we must not underestimate I want to
emphasize that from Germany's
perspective the status quo in the Taiwan
Strait can only be altered peacefully
and in agreement between the two sides
Professor Steve it's interesting that
this German delegation came at this
particular time what message if any does
this into China and is this a trip to
Taiwan that Beijing would take much
notice of
well Beijing will certainly take notice
and Beijing will disapprove of it but
what's the delegation is saying are
absolutely right that is how it should
be
um it will not go down well in China and
the Chinese government should realize
that for a German for for a delegation
from Germany which is very committed to
develop mutually beneficial
relationships with China to come out and
say so shows how far opinions in the
Democratic West has changed but it won't
be read that way Beijing will simply see
this delegation as being anti-chinese
okay if we can turn our attention back
to the Congress that's just taken place
there is a lot of speculation around the
former leader who Jintao who was quite
publicly and dramatically LED or forced
out of the Congress there are various
theories about what exactly happened
what's your take on all this
not the explanations are not completely
literally exclusive
we can see that's called Gentile is not
well
but to say that he was being removed
because of ill health I think is
stretching it
um he was not showing any signs of
distress when he was being removed his
distress comes from being removed
and if this was not planned
somebody would be punished for it
severely for embarrassing Xi Jinping at
the most important political event in
his 10 years of rule in China nobody has
been punished so it will have to be a
deliberate attempt by Xi Jinping to
humiliate who Gentile and set a clear
signal that the once Mighty Youth League
faction of which hujin Tao is still the
spiritual leader is no more now there is
only one leader in China and that is Xi
Jinping paid no attention to former
leaders or anybody else
speaking of leaders sir I'd like to ask
you finally about Lee Chung who's been
appointed China's second most powerful
leader who is he and what does his
appointment demonstrate
the leechang was a former Secretary of
Xi Jinping and he was well still is the
party Secretary of Shanghai and
therefore Department in Shanghai and he
made a mess of the civil code policy
earlier this year in Shanghai but he
remains totally loyal to Xi Jinping and
to the serial corporate policy and for
his loyalty he's been rewarded
promotions to the number two in
a senior person in China and almost
certainly the next Premier in this
spring
Professor Steve sang the director of the
China Institute at soas London we really
appreciate your insights today thank you
very much
thank you